all right let's go back to the lighter
side of car before we get there I'm
gonna ask you a couple of questions and
be as honest and controversial as you
want I'm never I'm so shy afraid of
expressing my opinions well what what is
the most controversial thing that you
believe is true that you think the
highest number of people would disagree
with you on in the industry okay the
best part about this question is people
know what their controversial thoughts
are and so you already know the top two
or three things you want to say so just
say just say number one I think there is
actually a less than zero percent chance
that Bitcoin will not succeed
interesting explain and that is um
I love Bitcoin it's there's so many
things about Bitcoin that are just
beautiful and just so incredibly well
designed and satoshi it was just
brilliant and not just in in its
technical design but the social design
the messaging around it the political
design there's so many things about
Bitcoin that are really elegant and
really interesting like fundamentally
innovative in that they challenge
long-held assumptions about how humans
can collaborate to get something done
which i think is really interesting but
i think the hard part with Bitcoin I
spent a lot of time in the Bitcoin
community from about 2014 to 2017 and
decentralization right is one of these
things that's appealing but
centralization creates efficiency
decentralization has a really high cost
and in Bitcoin decentralization has had
a really high social cost and I think
every day that goes by that Bitcoin
continues to operate in this sort of
very unstructured
is a day that talent flows to other
spaces and interest flows to other
spaces and like the Bitcoin community
doesn't necessarily do a great job being
communicative it doesn't do a great job
with the hearts and minds piece and I
think the predominant attitude whether
right or wrong is Bitcoin doesn't need
to change you need to change
I think that's unwelcoming and that
that's fine
but I think that kind of approach and
it's really the ideology and the mindset
of the Bitcoin community just makes it
tough for people to embrace it so I
agree with you that that's what's
happening what if they're not wrong
what what if actually part of the beauty
of Bitcoin is that whether you like it
or not it is a better design oh
absolutely it's not a flawed feature
yeah I agree with that and I think to a
hyper rational person and a thinker
who's been in the space and has the time
to really think about it that works yep
some people who don't have the
advantages of spending time and I think
that's the hard part
and again institutions now getting on
the Bitcoin bandwagon if they become the
mouthpiece that sells Bitcoin to the
broader retail and institutional
community they're gonna completely
bastardize all those ideas and just
steamroll everyone yep and destroy this
beautiful thing we spent ten years
building and so I think either the
Bitcoin community takes more ownership
of the narrative or someone else is
gonna do it for us yep we're gonna try
to do it and I just I worry about the
impact that we'll have and that's the
problem of social coordination right
that's always been the problem that's
the fundamental problem Bitcoin itself
with Byzantine fault tolerant consensus
mechanism tried to design for and it's
um it's a very hard problem part of it's
related to usability part of it's
related to just the language we use part
of it's related to the relative and
maturity of the tools we have to buy
sell trade hold store learn about a
plane but it's a big problem